«Was ist typisch amerikanisch an Brianna?
Ich würde sagen, der Enthusiasmus ...
... und nun fallen mir eher
nicht-amerikanische Dinge ein, ...
... die ich auch mag:
Ihr Interesse an anderen Kulturen, ...
... an fremden Ländern.
Und, dass sie eigentlich kein
extrovertierter Typ ist.»
«Typisch schweizerisch an Thomas ist:
Pünktlichkeit ...
... und Kompromissbereitschaft.
Wenn wir eine Meinungsverschiedenheit haben, ...
... oder er über seine Kollegen oder
seine Tochter spricht, ...
... sucht er immer einen  Kompromiss.
Das ist doch typisch schweizerisch.
Und das mag ich!»
«Wir trafen uns an einer Lehrer-Konferenz im Cern.
Es waren 50 Lehrer aus
40 verschiedenen Ländern dort.
Alles Partnerinstitutionen.
Alle kamen also da an, und das war
an meinem Geburtstag.
Am 5. Juli 2015 begann also diese Konferenz, ...
... welche dreieinhalb Wochen dauern sollte ...
... und ich erinnere mich nicht,
wann ich ihn zum ersten Mal sah.
Ich erinnere mich an nichts. Wir Amerikaner
hatten alle einen Jetlag.»
«Bevor wir geheiratet haben,
gingen wir mehrmals auf Reisen, ...
... jeweils zwei bis drei Wochen.
Auf diesen Reisen stellten wir fest,
dass wir mit Unterschiedlichkeiten umgehen können ...
... oder mit Konflikten.
Diese Momente waren für uns beide
manchmal eine Herausforderung ...
... und so stellten wir fest,
dass wir uns auch ergänzen.
Das war sehr positiv. Also dachten wir:
Es könnte klappen!»
«Als wir zum ersten Mal darüber sprachen
zusammen zu leben, sagte Thomas:
Wir haben drei Möglichkeiten.
Und ich dachte: Drei??
Er sagte: Du kommst zu mir,
ich komme zu Dir ...
... oder wir gehen sonst wohin.
Und ich sagte: Für mich
gibt es nur eine Möglichkeit.
Ich komme zu Dir!
Ich wollte schon immer in Europa leben.
Seit meiner ersten Reise, als ich 17 war.
Es ist kulturell einfach viel reicher.
Und nachdem ich dann hier ankam, dachte ich: Wow!
Das war eine grossartige Entscheidung!
Ich passe hierher.
Das ganze politische Klima.
Und wie sauber hier alles ist!»